when I was 23 I had a religious ceremony
with hundreds of witnesses but it turns
out that according to the law I wasn't
actually married at all healing and
accountability okay you've got traumas
that you went
through Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you can
asalam alaykum brothers and sisters and
dear friends so leaving off the
controversy that happened between Zade
and our sister Subhan Allah things have
come to light context has been brought
in and sadly like I said even though
Zade was wrong and I should apologize
the manipulation I'm not going to say
intentional unintentional was crazy yeah
from the sister side to make it out seem
like whatever but let's P that to a side
let's talk about the da F boys yes us me
Muhammad hijab you know um and you know
I mentioned um you know some other
people and they were like oh no we're
not talking about them we're talking
about you guys I was like oh thank you
very much Al so he was talking about us
and coming from who this French feminist
um Muslim uh sister you know Marian
Francis or whatever her name is for that
matter somebody who was known from the
get go from her early days when she came
to Islam wearing the hijab somewhat
correctly to go to turban to takeen off
that's her journey nobody's going to
have a GU out for that I would recommend
her to watch my video that I had with
the Saudi girl when it came to the hijab
um that's just a little from me to her
however brother sisters who is she what
do we know about her well mamm asked
some simple questions to her you know
why was she behaving in such a manner
instead of replying and explaining her
situation why she jumped to conclusion
just many sisters did one of them also
being our sisters from Solace I'm not
going to give a name I have nothing
person against you my dear sister
alhamdulillah I have nothing person
against you but you also jump to the
conclusion and many other people here um
I am holding myself back to name who are
still defending the sister yes some of
you guys know who you are why are you
not coming up and now clarifying and I
want to salute all the sisters in the
comment section cuz not all the sisters
are the same alhamdulillah calling that
sister out for again the manipulation
now here's a video we're going to watch
of this French feminist why is she so
eager like the French government to come
and change the Muslim world and how we
do things yes have you got the white man
syndrome to save us you know Muslims you
know from uh the shackles of the Shar
and you want to come and give us the
freedom watch this video where she was
involved in a documentary yes where
she's accusing all these da guys we are
F boys Etc we mess around we play around
but when the truth came out and context
was brought into it we not was saying
Zade was absolutely innocent this matter
let's make it clear yeah let's be just
here yes he he had to should apologize
which he did and we made the sister feel
but the sister's ulation and she she
made it out to be why are you not coming
out our sister is from Solace our sister
French French feminist sister yes why
are you not coming out miam yes why are
you not coming out and saying you know
what I'm sorry for jumping to
assumptions here is a video clip in a
Channel 4 documentary about Muslim
marriages watch for yourself to see what
we've been dealing with God knows for
the past how many years and it is coming
out now why because she has a personal
trauma because of a divorce that she
went through and now she's taken out on
the whole community and she's become a
super extreme radical feminist these
days a lot of people reject marriage but
this film isn't about people who don't
want to get married it's about women who
believe that they were married only to
find out that they actually W and what
we found is that this is an issue which
mainly affects Muslim women have you
been married in the UK yes I did
University be walked up in the UK and
believe that silly me with devastating
consequences for some I've dealt with
woman who' been left with Jord on the
street they've literally come in front
of the mosque saying my husband has just
thrown me out I can't prove that I'm
married to him I got cancer so we've
carried out the first ever major survey
of Muslim women's attitudes to marriage
in Britain the results showed that the
marriages of a high proportion of Muslim
couples are not legally recognized when
I was 23 I had a religious ceremony with
hundreds of witnesses but it turns out
that according to the law I wasn't
actually married at all so guys you saw
that for yourself Subhan Allah so you
can see she is now basically making it
seem as if the Islamic marriage the N is
not a valid nikah and is this as if the
Western system is more superior to the
Nik has given Allah subh T gave rights
to the Muslim woman long long long time
ago Subhan Allah this attitude where she
just come and why you can you can see it
you can clearly see she even mentioned
herself that she went through something
like that it's trauma you've gone
through trauma I'm sorry the trauma that
you've gone through but this is what we
see with a lot of single mothers not all
of them and a lot of divorced sisters
they all for some odd reason suddenly
wake up and become trauma coaches or
coaches or marriage counselors for some
odd reason do healing like sister soul
said in the M TR show healing and uh
accountability okay do some healing
you've got traumas that you went through
no problem we men go through traumas as
well I know many brother brothers who
have been broken by their ungrateful
wives who are taking the kids away from
them not letting them see the kids and
many other things okay we do not come
and blame every single sister and blame
them and put them all into the same
category just because you've gone
through through a specific trauma why
are you now on a rampage to at every
opportunity attacking everybody and you
know what's very interesting and bizarre
is that in the comment section on my
recent Tik Tok video I was basically
being told the following for my couple
of sister comments there okay some of
them yeah basically they were saying
that because they don't like the way we
do da I don't know what that means by
the way yeah they don't like our style
or whatever it is or you know I invite
individuals who I question and challenge
but for someone reason just because I
invite them don't care so because they
don't like the style we do da just
listen to this carefully because they
don't like how we do da it means that if
any kind of Scandal comes out about us
for example God forbid me Allah protect
my marriage aldah because most of you
sisters cannot be the dust underneath my
wife's feet so if my issue I had an
issue with my wife and my wife happened
to come out for some reason and
said um you know argum say Ali in know
marriage was something just anything
they're see we knew it we knew he was a
a misogynistic abuser he was beaten and
my wife could be crying and saying you
know what you know sorry I was just
shedding tears cuz I miss my husband he
like oh oh damn this is how perverted
some of you sisters are W you are
looking and hunting for our mistakes so
much so when that sister came out of
that information about Zade
misinformation manipulation um not
seeing on purpose gaslighting whatever
you want to call it everybody just
jumped these da guys and these da boys
and da why where was it coming from
because they didn't like our style of Da
and the things that we say which is from
Islam not from ourselves that's why that
justifies that if something or anything
comes out about them we will jump on it
and spread it like wildfire because we
don't like the way they do da you guys
are tapped in the head some of you
sisters are tapped in the head and for
that sister who's doing a video now
clarifying oh you sister you are the one
who came and said oh another da and then
then you have to take a video that why
are none of you guys coming out and now
saying we are sorry for jumping an
accusation and slander why has that
sister our dear sister um ran I think
that's her name is why is your video
still up my dear sister and for this
French toast feminist yes she's a french
toast feminist Mariam whatever her name
is for that matter yes we don't need
your French values your Western values
do not need it in Islam come to Islam
fully embracing it or don't that's
totally up to you but just because you
had a bad experience and let me guess
your ex-husband was a narcissist a
gaslighting manipulating evil man I bet
you're watching something yeah oh my
gosh how do you know Ali for some odd
reason all your ex-husbands are like
that take accountability if a brother
comes to me and says my wife was this I
say brother hold on a second man I need
a full story you know what about you I
mean what kind of person are you I'm not
going to come and now believe that every
time if a group of brothers keep coming
to me and seeing my ex-wife this I'm
going to say brother hold on a second
all of your Ex-Wives are evil and you
guys are angels I'm so sorry I'm going
to take you guys to account yeah what
are you doing to make this woman feel
like this we as men take each other to
account so this is a message to this
foulmouthed French toast feminist woman
who is calling us Dow guys F boys yes
have some shame okay we don't need your
French values your Western French toast
values to come into Islam and try to
dilute it we have Islam and you are also
known to attack prominent classic
scholars in a video which I will tag in
brother sisters so we know what this
woman is exactly about and when she's
challenged even by Muhammed by asking
questions we get a block okay so her
emotional as you can see emotions are
all over the place up and down inshallah
it will get steady and may Allah heal
your heart and don't allow your traumas
to inshallah call be a means to blame
everybody paint everybody with the same
brush and call us St boys F boys you are
a Shameless vile mouth foulmouthed woman
uh and may Allah subhana T guide you
that's all I have to
sayum I'm going to leave some inshah
links you guys can watch the documentary
that she was in inah and it says a lot
about
herself the prophet sallu wasallam said
whoever builds a Masid for the sake of
Allah subhana wa tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tala tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atam weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid oh Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
[Music]